shemar Moore who plays Hondo on I guess
would you call the rebooted SWAT on CBS
rebooted you know I don't remake is not
it you know no I'm just heard the theme
song we brought that back yes a yeah we
brought in 99 I know I know when I was a
kid running around playing GI Joe with
that beam song oh yeah oh yeah you had
to do it with the broomstick and that
was chasing bad guys but and then you
know the last person to play Hondo hmm
was samuel l.jackson now if you think
i'm about to try to fill the shoes of
sam jackson you smoke his uncle well so
no this is the Shamal more version
2017-2018 but it's it's it's it's the
same name it's the same theme song same
font of the letters but it's it's today
it's the Trump years without talking
about Trump it's it's not Apollo
political show we're not preaching we're
having a bunch of fun crazy action but
we're also tackling issues that are
happening today when you turn on the
news there's a lot of crazy stuff going
on in this country and around the world
and we want to tackle those things and
but give you more of an optimistic
approach and maybe give you a
sensibility maybe maybe
exhale maybe try to bridge the gap try
to create a debate a conversation sure
try to dig beneath the surface look past
the cover of the book the color of the
skin you know just try to create a
little more unity now as a TV show gonna
fix the woes of the world probably not
but if we can give you a more optimistic
view on people just being people the men
and women of blue the yes they are
superheroes yes they risk their lives
every day they're also not perfect they
make mistakes but then also for the men
and women in blue to view civilians and
just and to say okay let's let's create
a different temperament let's have a
little more patience let's let's dig
beneath the surface let's take the time
to talk to each other try to understand
each other understand both sides because
we all bleed red black white green and
yellow we're human beings we're brothers
and sisters we just got to understand
each other at least take the time to try
the Mets Thursday nights on CBS coming
off of a month-long break of this coming
Thursday 10:00 Eastern Time SWAT and
Shamar more right here on the Rich Eisen
show now you were born in Oakland
correct I was born oh you associate
yourself with with Oakland or deal
here's the deal I'm half black half
white my father's black my mother's
white
so I grew up a Raider fan okay man
Oakland guy I'm definitely a Golden
State Warriors fan not just because of
the splash brothers I remember Bernard
King and world be free oh okay back when
I was an ardent King now by the way you
know he wasn't a one of the all-time
great New York Knicks - that's my guy I
mean we're right around the same age
even though you it looks much better on
you what did I say black don't crack
baby good let me flip it though the
white side of you Boston so before I
came out here you were playing at that
Pittsburgh Patriot yeah yeah at that
catch yeah she's BS all day long and I
fight with my family in Boston because
they are Brady this Brady dad Brady
should run for president Brady's God and
I respect Brady because he's just really
good his times right
but this Brady factor this you can't
touch him all this but that was a catch
okay a runner you get you got the ball
you run you can just put your arm over
the line and it's good he caught the
ball two steps he was a run who talked
about Earth's in the end yeah in masu
yes and then I went to and then I went
out to Boston for Christmas and I and I
played Santa Claus for my family and I
got him 20 tickets to the Buffalo
Patriots game okay
freezing my tail off it's Boston East
Coast where there's no joke I'm a
California dude yeah but I'm at the game
freeze and can't feel my knees my hands
nothing
Brady stunk in the first half first time
I ever seen him live he stunk I was like
this is what the hypes all about but
then in the second half
he did what he does yes but then again
the catch in the end zone with the
dragon toe oh you're talking about
Kelvin Benjamin is that was one of who
who was it Peter King when I came on the
show Brockman said that that was one of
the worst failures I'm history
cork thio you saw the line of the toe I
know he's funny we had we have a
relationship with Funny or Die here
Shamar and we had a we came up with a
fake
pill that you take before you take on
the New England patients called
patriotic state rethink the bills
clearly didn't take it because strange
things kind of do happen when they take
on the Patriots sometimes so okay so so
when you were saying that your warriors
fan and you don't want to be seen as a
front-runner right now I mean you
mentioned splash brothers that's you
know obviously the two guys that are
right there in the backcourt right now
all that said you know
it's got to be the great yeah it's funny
how you you have a problem with the
Patriots and how they they keep winning
non-stop mmm it seems like you've got
your version in basketball
I'm so happy Oakland Oakland you know I
rumor is you know it's a strong rumor
that they're gonna lose the Raiders and
there's lots of Vegas happening
I know it is and that just man there's
only one freeway it's just like no other
Raiders there's its Oakland it's the
town I'm from the bay I'm from 98th
Avenue behind the Coliseum but it's good
to see the city on fire meaning just to
see that they've got so much to be
excited about you know I mean you go
back to Oakland goes back to the Black
Panthers the civil rights you know
Oakland Oakland is a legendary legendary
city but to have these two teams you
know I knew the Raiders when it was
Plunkett and Lester Hayes you know and
so all that history and you're gonna
send them to Vegas but with the splash
brothers I mean it's a it's a new day of
basketball what Steph and klay are doing
now cadiz out their dream on it's just
it's so fun to watch these guys but
basketball that game is so fun in that
house it's ours out Pachulia dirty or
clumsy unless I'm a lien on the clumsy
triple you'll trip over nothing you lean
on the class baby flop Hey okay but no I
I do love watching them play and I think
Steve Kerr is a phenomenal coach and I
understand Luke Walton won a lot of
games Walker was out I just think what
he does is you and me could coach that
team you think though and I mean not
really not really and no no disrespect
to Luke Walton because he put in his
time and right I think I think he's
proven to be a good coach he writes he
knows his stuff but at that time when
Kerr went out I mean they were just a
fine oiled machine and then you add KD
to that it's not fair ask LeBron if it's
fair it's just not fair I mean you know
me I mean it was crazy at the all-star
getting to see LeBron and KD on you know
on the same and that's why I thought
that what what what was about what what
they did this year for the all-star game
Shamar
worked that that that there's LeBron and
Kady teaming up to beat khari literally
they were the two that that penned him
in would not let him he had to pass it
off to divorce Rosa
that showed me and then a chest bump
like they just won the finals together
right I love that no I really enjoy here
was a good time this year I you know
outside of Fergie I mean look I I'm a
fan the girl can sing yes she tried to
do this maybe it was the Marvin Gaye
thing or I tried to do it it just you
know didn't quite work but I still kudos
to her it just you know yes
but outside of that I you know Kevin
Hart doing his thing running his mouth
the introductions to the the the players
he was putting his little spin on it
that was fun
no it was a party it was a party it was
like great no second to the Super Bowl
but see you were there you were there
for no no I'm a couch for house and
barbecuing and okay and yelling at the
TV and have a good time but no this year
this year was a good time you know what
I didn't know what I thought the dunk
contest was not what it normally is for
guys and the rules are different
Jamar more SWAT here on the Rich Eisen
show I like the three-point contest more
yeah I think that that is more of a
skill than somebody who's looking and
III very hesitant to say anything
because I can maybe jump 4 inches right
so I understand what they are doing what
Larry Nance Jr did was stupid ridiculous
and Donovan
where were you because I didn't think
because he's so big and because his
dunks were incredible the windmill stuff
yeah and the tribute to his father but
that little double tap I didn't think
that was so amazing it was just that big
and he was right there I just I couldn't
believe that he was able to actually
that one I thought was the most
impressive dunk of them all in slow
motion they realized what happened you
know no even in the arena we needed to
see in the second time and it was a WOW
factor then not really live it was a WOW
factor then I think they're out of ideas
Oh in all honesty you know they've
jumped over Kevin Hart's kids now
they've
name one Donovan Mitchell okay you bring
out Kevin Hart you bring out his family
if you dump ten feet you have to get a
certain height you have the shortest man
in the world and you make him duck I'm
like we've got to get up there anyway
like what are you doing I mean I could
jump over Kevin Hart and I can dunk a
tennis ball maybe on a good day and pull
a hamstring but you make Kevin Hart duck
you lost me right there I mean unless it
was a joke no I think you did it for
real right there they made him duck well
I guess he just he knows what he's
probably his net worth is he didn't want
to it's a liability I guess it's good to
see you Congrats on all your success
thankful all those years on Young and
the Restless and then all those years in
Criminal Minds now as you said front and
center right there on SWAT CBS yeah
continued success
thank you man means a lot and come back
any time oh no no I'm a fan all day
respect to what you do thank you I
appreciate you saying that and I know
again I'm appreciative because I'm sure
you're working eight days a week pretty
much but it's all right great
Thursday night 10:00 Eastern Time SWAT
on CBS Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience